cypriots have never known anything but
division in their lives in this part of
Nicosia and right across two-thirds of
the island greek-speaking cypriots are
in the majority walk through this
checkpoint and after the buffer zone
you're in this self-declared Republic of
Northern Cyprus one Cyprus is wishful
thinking that's what this Turkish
cypriot shopkeeper thinks
when you look at Cyprus dividing it into
North and South is the source of the
problem for our country the problems
multiply and grow
in the South a Greek cypriot Baker is
also cynical
our people Everyone is thinking about
their own personal interests all the
politicians up to now I haven't seen one
politician who loves their country their
lands they love their position and the
ones closest to them
the foreign minister of Cyprus says
there has to be more outside help if
there's to be any hope of a political
solution we need some help from the
International Community and in
particular from countries that can work
with turkey but everybody stands to gain
not just the stakeholders
Cyprus the two communities
Turkey Greece but also European union
and also the allies
Turkish separate leaders here weren't
available for comment their position on
talks is based on preconditions and they
include demands for a two-state solution
five years ago there was a different
leadership in place and they were more
moderate
they had been prepared to accept a
federation based on their demands
those talks took place in 2017 in the
Swiss Alps they were the closest anyone
had come to a deal but they failed at
the last minute osdale Nami had been
Chief negotiator for the Turkish cypriot
leadership he says now there's only one
way out of the stalemate that can only
be I'm going to a new referendum and
asking people whether they want a
federation or a two-state solution so
that once and for all we remove
continuation of the status score from
among alternatives
cypriot people from both sides are worn
down by their situation yet when it
comes to voting many stick to the status
quo for now despite Decades of Frozen
conflict change seems to be a distant
Prospect Andrew Simmons Al Jazeera
Nicosia